[Music]
my name is riley sawyers and I'm a past
president and this year's PR chairman
for the world's largest Sweetwater JC's
Rattlesnake Roundup
it all started back in 1958 when area
farmers and ranchers came to the JC's
and said hey man y'all know we got tons
of rattlesnakes now let's catch them and
do something with well really about 1959
1960 it started growing more media
started getting involved and more people
started hearing about it and it just has
grown tremendously so there's about
thirty to forty thousand people a year
come to Sweetwater where we live and do
business had a we prefer not to every
step he takes their rattlesnakes so well
that's one reason we have the roundup is
just own population control we catch up
approximate average of about 5,000
pounds a year hunters will start
bringing those snakes in we buy them for
a nominal fee they're thrown into a pit
and from that pit they go to the milking
pit where you actually take the venom
out of their glands and from that
station they go to research where
they're measured sex and weight and that
information is sent to the Texas Parks
and Wildlife for them to do their
studies and make limits or suggestions
or whatever just like any other wildlife
and then from that station they go to
probably one of the favorite ones of
everybody's where the blood and guts are
we call it this Canton pit her head is a
chopped off skin and then part
rattlesnakes are used we end up cooking
to me making meals while it's boots
whatever out of the highs
it's a wonderful event with just not
about snakes we we have a gun not going
so a carnival fleamarket
a cook-off that hosts about 125 to 150
teen and just a lot of entertainment for
the individual or family for nine or the
weekend
[Music]